congressional Democrats and Republicans
are selecting their new leadership
following the midterm elections in the
house CBS News estimates Democrats will
gain at least 32 seats once all the
results are in that puts the Republicans
in the minority for the first time since
2010
House Republicans yesterday picked
California congressman Kevin McCarthy to
serve as Minority Leader he fended off a
challenge from freedom caucus member Jim
Jordan congressman McCarthy joins us now
from Capitol Hill good morning good
morning thank you so much for having me
yeah it's nice to see you
congratulations on your selection I know
that you've acknowledged that your party
took a beating in some of these suburban
swing districts suburban in women and
particularly swung for the Democrats
does the Republican Party have a problem
with women well we have a lot of room to
grow we don't have a problem per se just
with women it's not one item of why we
lost the majority there's there's a
number of them first you have history
one of the things that happens when a
party wins the White House on average
they lose 32 seats
President Obama lost 63 so we knew
history was against it we had too many
retirements the most retirements we've
had in for more than 41 individuals
retiring we have amazing women serving
in the House and they moved up you look
at Christine oma is going to become the
first woman governor of North South
Dakota you look at Marsha Blackburn is
going to be the first woman senator of
Tennessee and then we lost seats more
money on the other side and the one
thing about going into the minority you
can always improve so yeah I think
you're going to find great improvement
from us and especially in the suburban
area and maybe in the suburban agenda
leader McCarthy I want to show you the
pictures of the incoming House
Republicans freshmen and the incoming
freshmen Democrats you have for the
Democrats
there are 19 new women for the
Republicans how many new women do you
have well we have two right now one is
young Kim who was born in South Korea
she's a leading in the polls and this is
a real this is a challenge we had
because a number of our women ran for
higher office and moved out and it was
the year of the woman if you look at the
Democrats a Republican Party no it
wasn't a much we have we have room for
but if you look at in the Democratic
primaries where there was an open seat
and it was a woman versus a man a woman
won 69 percent of the time so of course
they had more women coming forward we
can do better in recruitment and that's
what I'm excited about doing but also
look at who else is coming in as
freshmen Republicans if you look Dan
Crenshaw a veteran working on that
service if you look at Mike Waltz the
first Green Beret officer we're diverse
but we continue to expand and improve it
one thing about my leadership is
constant improvement that's good we
could all use constant improvement join
you on that but let's talk about the
diversity issue too because they had a
very interesting picture congressman the
other day on the Republican side it
seemed to be a lot of white guys in
suits on the Republican side on the
Democratic side on the Republican side a
lot of white guys in suits on the
Democratic side you saw women you saw
people of color are you worried about
diversity too is that another area so it
looks and we need to improve on that too
yeah we had a number of people who had
lost seats that would fit in different
categories like that Carlos Cabello and
others we didn't win in the in some of
these seats and I look at improvement I
look at an ability to move forward and
that is one area will continue to work
forward on congressman one of the things
we hear from women and minorities is
that they were turned off by the
president's rhetoric his tone you had a
good working relationship with the
president in fact it was noted that at
times you bring him starbursts what if
anything Jerry and Jerry and
strawberries in particular why did what
can you tell him about his rhetoric and
what needs to be changed look tone
matters a lot where we're going but I
think would happen and you watched it in
that presidential election in campaigns
people battle and I think people were
getting frustrated on both sides of the
aisle if you watched in the last
presidential election for Republican to
Democrat I want someone who would fight
through and they made a decision and the
president hasn't changed from who he was
as a candidate to who he is today but I
think there's always a way to bring more
people together I look at what happened
in the White House yesterday you look at
the bipartisanship that happen for
criminal justice reform now a lot of
people have tried to do that pass
administration's have tried to do that
we're on the brink of making that happen
we passed it in the house and when I
looked in the Senate yesterday it made
all criteria of what you're asking me
about sitting inside the White House
with President Trump as president making
this happen getting through the Senate
yeah hang out that'll come back and
become law so yes there's places for
improvement but there's also places he's
been very successful in and I look at
the final part of the results yes
Oh leader McCarthy I understand that you
have interviewed at the White House with
the president for the job of White House
chief of staff would you take that job
you know I have not interviewed for that
job and I have a job I was just elected
to look I have a focus our number-one
goal here is to make sure we move
America Forward I will work with anyone
who wants to work to make America better
I have a second job as becoming the
Republican leader to win that majority
back and I'm focused on that and that
will be my job in the next and that
includes working with Nancy Pelosi if
she is a fact speaker yeah whoever
becomes Speaker I can work on the other
side of the aisle with them any place
that we can find improvement but we have
to remember to when elections are over
we should govern if the agenda is just
gonna be investigations mhm I think
America is too great for such a small
vision let's think about how do we make
America than the next century ours what
are we doing about prospered solving our
veterans problem we did well combating
opioids with our bill bipartisan what we
did to transform and stop human
trafficking online we're just doing
criminal justice there are a lot of
places we can work together let's put
those things that divide as a side and
you talk about this a more perfect union
we have an opportunity this is an
exceptional country America will always
be the greatest when we find our places
that we can work together and make sure
the next century is ours well you need
to spread that word to some of your
colleagues I know the president calls
you Mike Evan of all the nicknames that
he's come up with Mike Evan sounds
pretty good Mike Evans all right with me
all right
you bye Mike Evan